cuando japón se enfrentó a una crisis en
su banco en los años 90
lo primero que comenzó a bajar fue su
tasa de interés o la tasa con la que los
bancos realizaban préstamos de sus
reservas uno con el otro y bien la forma
de realizar esto es imprimiendo dinero
en el caso del banco central de japón
imprimieron bienes e invirtiendo a corto
plazo en valores gubernamentales pero el
subproducto de todo esto es la
incremento de la cantidad de la moneda
de las reservas en circulación y así los
bancos tienen más reservas así que la
demanda de dichas reservas bajarán o el
costo del préstamo bajará y con esto a
su vez la tasa de interés pero japón
hizo esto y no exactamente de esta forma
ellos obtuvieron el 0 por ciento de tasa
de interés pero luego lo que realmente
se podría deducir es que la tasa se
incrementó un poquito más ya que es lo
que exactamente bernanke enfrentó con
eeuu y su crisis de crédito bueno ya
japón le ocurrió esto porque todo
depende de que ellos querían más y más
dinero entrando en circulación así que
vamos a mantener imprimiendo más yenes
pero en realidad esto no dejó ninguna
utilidad
sirvió para comprar a corto plazo la
deuda porque si se quisiera hacer un
precio que vaya haciéndose cada vez más
y más alto a la vez irá siendo débil
pues se ha bajado a corto plazo la tasa
de interés tanto como ha sido posible
bueno y así se comenzaron a usar las
cosas para comercializar otras
obteniendo este dinero en circulación de
cualquier forma que se cancelara algo
era por su larga duración y con el
lanzamiento de estos tesoros japoneses
permitieron que las empresas compraran
deuda corporativa así que ellos no
compraron realmente un buen bonche de
cosas su intención era literalmente
clara sólo quedan incrementar la
cantidad e incrementar la cantidad de
dinero así que lo que los japoneses
hicieron fue una especie de poder de
flexibilización cuantitativa ellos
estuvieron intentando imprimir dinero a
cualquier costo y dejaron que ese dinero
entrar en circulación de cualquier forma
y es posible que ellos hubieran podido
comprar demasiadas cosas para realizarlo
en cambio bernanke hizo algo similar o
con el mismo mecanismo pero hubo algo
diferente a los japoneses ellos
intentaron
trabajar a corto plazo las tasas de
interés presentando valores a corto
plazo e incrementaron la cantidad de
reservas en circulación de la noche a la
mañana todo esto bajo una tasa
restringida y bajando las tasas de los
fondos federales pero cuando ellos
lograron ese 0 por ciento habían
comprado ya todo esto y dijeron bueno y
ahora cómo vamos a solucionar el
estancamiento de los mercados de crédito
y quemándose las manos todo esto los
inclinaba hacia un solo camino que lo
llevaba a comenzar a imprimir más dinero
y esta vez lo iban a utilizar para
comprar bienes que hicieran reservas
federales y no lo que tradicionalmente
se compraba y japón lo hizo bastante
bien la diferencia surge en que así es
como bernanke explica las diferencias
que él no vio en esto porque
mecánicamente se podrá decir que si es
lo mismo pero él lo llama
flexibilización del crédito y la
diferencia radica en que bernanke si
tenía intenciones de incrementar la
demanda de algunos de los tipos de
valores donde la liquidez quizás tenía
estancamiento y no sólo por hacerlo